But make no mistake...
...this cannot solely be America's endeavor.
Those who used to chastise America for acting alone in the world...
...cannot now stand by and wait for America to solve the world's problems alone.
We have sought in word and deed,...
...a new era of engagement with the world.
This body is made up of sovereign states.
And sadly, but not surprisingly,...
...this body has often become a forum for sowing discord instead of forging common ground.
A venue for playing politics and exploiting grievances rather than solving problems.
After all, it is easy to walk up to this podium and point figures,...
...point fingers and stoke divisions.
Nothing is easier than blaming others for our troubles,...
...and absolving ourselves of responsibility for our choices and our actions.
Anybody can do that.
Responsibility and leadership in the 21st century demand more.